وبالفعل تحدث عن ملفين اساسيين الملف
الاول وان روسيا سترد على امداد بريطانيا
بالاسلحه والبخائر الولايات المحتوى
المجرانيوم المنظم للقوات الاوكرانيه وانا
بالفعل قد قامت بانجاز القوات البيلاروسيه
بطائرات الاسلحه والمخائر النوويه تكتيكيه
وانها ايضا من الاعتبار من بلاد الشرق
القادم ستقوم بتشييد مخازن للرخائر
النوويه وتنتحدث عن
النوويه التي ستقوم بريطانيا بتزويد اكواد
الاوكرانيه بها هي لا تدخل في اطار تصنيف
اسلحه الدمار الشامل ولكنها يمكن ان تسبب
غبار يؤثر على المناطق الزراعيه ويؤثر
ايضا على السكان وبالتالي الغرب هو من
اقدم على هذه الخطوه وروسيا مضطره للرد
على هذا الاجراء ايضا
بتوفير العوامل والضمانات الاساسيه لحمايه
امنها وامن حلفائها اما يتعلق الثاني كما
هو استخدام الصيني في التعاملات
الاقتصاديه على مستوى